welcome back to new rockstars i'm
whitney van laningham and yippee dippy
do mfers take off your shoes and strap
on your walkie because we're doing a die
hard in episode two of rick and morty
season six we're faced with two plots
summer versus alien burglars obsessed
with the greatest christmas movie of all
time
the greatest christmas movie of all time
and rick desperately trying to free
morty's fractured soul from the depths
of a video game glitch so today i'm
breaking down all the details you might
have missed in rick a mortwell live
let's kick things off with that title
rick a mortwell lived is a play on roy a
life well lived the video game first
introduced in season two's multiplicity
when rick takes morty to blips and chits
for the first time and scares the [ __ ]
out of his grandson doesn't realize that
he's playing a time dilated rpg
simulation where you live a full life as
a man named roy each second of time in
the real world is equivalent to roughly
one month inside the game this week's
outing to blips and chits is ruined by a
group of thieves who cause a power
outage that forces the game to restart
while morty is playing around with roy
as a result roy glitches out and
splinters morty's consciousness across 5
billion non-player characters that make
up the simulation to remedy this rick
has to jack in as roy and convince as
many fragments of morty's consciousness
as possible to work together and leave
the planet before the game ends and
morty's mind is lost forever while her
grandpa is fighting with pieces of her
brother inside roy summer's off fighting
off the alien burglars who are obsessed
with 1988's die hard and ho ho ho does
this episode jam in as many die hard
references as they can get away with
even the a and b plots are tied together
by a missable die-hard reference when
sergeant al powell first asks for john
mcclane's name in die-hard mclean tells
him that his name is roy after one of
his favorite western actors roy rogers
obviously rick also uses the alias roy
in this episode and structurally like
mclean rick and summer are both
attempting to save hostages with rick's
hostage being a box of oops all mortys
rick refers to the aliens as terrorists
before he taps back into the game which
is what die hard's villain german hans
gruber convinces law enforcement his
group is but like these aliens gruber's
team was actually just elaborate robbers
using terrorism as a cover rick also
instructs summer to crawl around the
vents just like bruce willis does alien
john's gruber voiced by the supremely
talented peter dinklage asks the manager
of the arcade to point them to the safe
when they insist that there is no safe
hit blips and jits jon shoots them in
the head similar to the way that hans
gruber interrogates joseph tagaki about
the access codes to the vault containing
640 million in bearer bonds at nakatomi
plaza before killing him with a head
shot like willis and die hard summer
gives away her position by making noise
after witnessing this murder though
mclean just gasped and didn't activate a
don't touch me game taking rick's advice
summer climbs through the vents before
dropping to the floor like mclean in
front of skee-balls where she begins to
fight a terrorist named frank the two
fall mid-fight and summer accidentally
squishes him into a delicious goo this
is a reference to the scene in die hard
when john mclean kills his first
terrorist tony by accidentally breaking
his neck although she's never seen the
movie summer realizes that walkie talkie
communication must also be a key element
of die hard which it is because after
tony shuts down the phone lines that was
the best way to communicate in the late
80s while scurrying around a skyscraper
like a goddamn rogue when jon's last
summer frank is still alive she responds
that he's not playing die hard he's
playing die easy an alien gruber's right
hand man winslow becomes enraged this is
likely because frank was his brother
just like tony was gruber's right-hand
man carl's brother the name winslow is
also likely inspired by sergeant
powell's actor reginald val johnson's
other notable police character carl
winslow from family matters seeing as
these aliens share similarities with the
gungans from star wars winslow's head
shake could also be a reference to boss
nasa's angry shake in the phantom menace
in the same way that mclean refuses to
say his real name over the walkie to
avoid gruber's men discovering his and
his wife's identities summer simply
tells jon's that her name is die hard
and says walkie-talkie die hard
[ __ ] as an homage to bruce
willis's iconic line from the movie
john gruber explains that every sentient
civilization in the entire multiverse
eventually develops their own myth of
die hard although the story's name
varies from place to place this is a
real world phenomenon known as
comparative mythology and folklore where
different cultures independently create
their own stories with strikingly
notable similarities for instance there
are over 500 global iterations of a rags
to riches princess similar to cinderella
within rick and morty's universe there
is the die-hard parallel tower man from
alpha centauri where gobo the alien
featured in morty's mind blowers lived
before he was accidentally left in a hot
car by the smith family as we see at the
climax tower man's ending diverges a bit
from die hard with the right hand
henchmen transforming into a flying
beast folks in orion's belt refer to
their die hard fable as the thornburg
cycle which is a reference to die hard's
[ __ ] newscaster richard thornberg
those from the andromeda galaxy where
the planet zorpazorp is located have
dubbed it foolish to imagine you'd be
able to kill when summer escapes winslow
hunts her down standing on top of a long
table as he blows holes in it with his
gun he advises summer that next time she
tries to do a die hard she shouldn't
hide under a long table like the guy
from die hard he's referencing the scene
where mclean's adversary warns him that
the next time he has a shot he should
take it of course mclean seizes the time
he spends telling him that to shoot it
which is exactly what summer does to
this dude when we next see john's he's
reading a book he wrote on die hard
called the nakatomi paradigm paradigm is
a fancy word for pattern so his book
likely isn't just a novelization of die
hard but it's also an anthropological
look at the comparative mythologies that
span the universe telling the die-hard
tales han speaks aloud his next plan i'm
going to wander the arcade unarmed and
when she comes across me i'll pretend to
be a hostage because she hasn't seen the
scene in die hard where alan rickman
puts on an american accent and tries to
trick bruce willis jones assumes that
she won't know to hand him an unloaded
gun like mclean did to gruber
unfortunately he doesn't expect her to
just start wildly screaming die hard die
hard die hard because summer is going
off script the other alien proclaims
that he doesn't want to shoot the glass
a nod to the famous scene where hans
gruber orders his crew to take out the
glass inside nakatomi because mclean is
walking around barefoot like a goddamn
wikifeed ad as soon as john's realizes
that summer's family is inside blips and
shits like gruber does when he discovers
that holly gennaro is actually john
mcclane's estranged wife he decides to
threaten her with rick and morty's lives
the other alien busts out a boombox and
starts playing joy by beethoven hans
gruber's theme song in the movie the
tune also plays when safe cracker theo
finally opens the vault summer appears
to face grouper hands held above her
head and surrender as she approaches him
he says and the quarterback as they say
is toast which is what theo exclaims
after nailing the lapd's armored truck
with a missile he then asks her i don't
suppose you have a gun taped to your
back a move you'll recall is john
mcclane's final genius solution to
taking out the bad guys when he repeats
their catchphrase walkie-talkie die-hard
[ __ ] causing the two of them to
giggle summer reminds john's that
mcclain and gruber also shared a weird
burst of laughter right before bruce
willis totally smoked alan rickman and
confesses that she read his copy of the
nakatomi paradigm in the bathroom like
summer mclean also spent some down time
in the bathroom during die hard he
wasn't reading though he was trying to
get those tootsie witsy money makers
back in action probably just in time for
pulp fiction bearing john's final
moments he says cocter off elysium which
is german for daughter of elysium and
the second line of og joy when winslow
returns he tells summer that he only
joined john's crew because of the shame
he felt after accidentally eating a kid
he claims that it was dark and you
thought he was a grown-up which is
pretty much what sergeant powell says
when he confesses to mclean that he
accidentally shot a kid in his past as
an active duty police officer the alien
eats jon's gruber and flies away robbing
us of the chance to see summer push him
off the top of blips and shits we here
at new rockstars love pub trivia knowing
deep cut trivia is kind of our thing but
we also love being able to roll into
work after having a celebratory ipa or
two without feeling like crud and that's
why we love zebiotics zebiatix is a
probiotic drink that breaks down a toxic
byproduct of alcohol it's not
dehydration that makes you feel like
garbage the morning after drinking it's
that byproduct i mean water is good for
you obviously stay hydrated but drink
azebiotics as well z biotics is a real
science that works drink antibiotics
drink responsibly pace yourself and
you're good to go it's nice to be able
to have a beer or two tonight without
having to worry about tomorrow morning
and see biotics can help give you that
peace of mind you should give it a try
get 15 off your first order of xebiotix
pre-alcohol probiotic by clicking the
link in the description box and using my
code new rockstars at checkout go to
xebiotix.com new rockstars and get 15
off on your first order the final die
hard reference appears in the episode's
tag this scene is an homage to the
beginning of die hard 3. when hans
gruber's brother simon played by jeremy
irons threatens to set off bombs if the
nypd doesn't cooperate he forces them to
send john mcclane to harlem wearing a
sandwich board with a racial slur where
he's found in the street by samuel l
jackson zeus carver in this scene jon
sgruber's brother and his right-hand man
are spying on an alien wearing and i
hate everyone's sandwich board sign
hoping to provoke similar violence with
that die-hard feast out of the way let's
transition to breaking down the a plot
which grappled with some heftier
concepts in this week's inside the
episode creator dan harmon explains that
this episode plays with the intersection
between simulation theory and religion
obviously simulation theory is the
hypothesis that existence is a
matrix-like simulated reality being run
by a highly advanced computer much like
many religions the minutia of an
individual's day-to-day life within a
simulation is miniscule to the grander
design set in motion by a higher power
in the broad sense the episode covers
universal aspects of many religions
including the belief or trust that a
higher power has your salvation or at
the very least a salvation at heart we
see this at play with the morty npcs
having to trust rick roy with their
ascension to becoming one
fourteen-year-old boy who loves
masturbation and pizza more particularly
though this episode is a sci-fi parallel
to the religious concept called pandeism
this is the belief that all beings are
fractured parts of one higher
consciousness that cease to exist when
it created the universe related concepts
such as pantheism and panentheism
similarly dictate that we are all
aspects of one universal being inside
the game of roy we open on a group of
teens hanging out at choi's grocery one
of the first signs we have that things
aren't as they appear is that all the
characters are voiced by justin roiland
doing variations on his morty voice this
is a playful jab at the entire show as
royland already voices pretty much every
character including all the ricks and
all the mortys as we learn holy's
characters are limited by stereotypical
knowledge held by mortys so it's
especially scathing that dorky morty's
version of being a cool kid amounts to
skaters doing rad tricks you can't name
one ollie or christ dare canyon morty
play goddamn tony hockey dweeb actually
seeing these various facets of morty's
personality personified across the
spectrum of the npcs reminds me a lot of
season three's rest and relaxation in
which morty's toxic essence was sucked
out of him leaving only the good parts
of him unfortunately with no doubt
embarrassment anger or other
quote-unquote toxic emotions that
version of morty becomes a mini patrick
bateman here we're seeing something
similar with each npc embodying a
specific part of what makes morty morty
and we're left to question how morty
will change if certain parts of him were
left behind this plot mostly follows
marta an aspect of morty that houses his
greatest potential to be a great
unifying leader rix roy has trouble at
first convincing the npcs that they're
all his grandson morty until marta
eventually rises to the occasion as a
figurehead for this cause marta comes
from morty's idea of a devoted jewish
family and she represents new age
thinking that questions religious
traditions as the morty ideology begins
to spread especially among the younger
generation within the game we start to
see little campaigns and slogans pop up
for the cause the sign on the door of
the grandson gathering says welcome
grandsons when the fuzz busts in to
arrest roy for doing religion wrong you
can see posters in the background that
read we're all grandsons and mortys
unite to be honest i was a little bummed
out that the npc morty's band song about
being part of the collective of
grandsons wasn't a full parody of smells
like teen spirit because that hello
hello
really got me excited there for a second
roy and marta eventually visit president
leland an old-fashioned and vaguely
southern version of morty that
apparently calls women things like honey
and pumpkin tits in his office you can
see pictures of what appears to be
abraham lincoln a fisherman james monroe
andrew jackson and george washington
hung in his office there's also the
painting buffalo ball grazing on the
prairie painted in 1830 by george
caitlin which actually hung in the oval
office during kennedy's presidency the
president explains that eight percent of
morty doesn't innately trust roy slash
rick because despite the fact that he's
been campaigning for 50 years to save
his mind he's never once said i love you
to any of them when marta confronts roy
about this he flippantly tells her that
he's willing to lose eight percent of
morty's consciousness because in the
grand scheme of things eight percent
isn't that terrible of a loss he argues
that eight percent of the snyder cut is
just batman dreaming i did some rough
math and it turns out that only 2.8 of
the snyder cut is batman dreaming but
funnily enough ign also did some math
and they found that 10.38
of the snyder cut is in slow-mo which
likely accounts for rick's slight
miscalculation because rick's so willing
to leave marta in her homeland behind
the morty npcs start a holy war between
the formerly peaceful involved countries
on their zoom call you can see the flags
of representatives from poland india
rwanda south africa cuba spain america
senegal china israel italy great britain
liechtenstein korea vietnam japan
pakistan new zealand switzerland canada
finland australia and brazil the npcs on
mardis side revolt desiring to live out
their lives within the game instead of
returning to the real world they end up
dividing into two factions loyalist of
acucratic randinistas whose symbol is
the letter r in honor of roy rick and a
star and ship representing rick's plans
to return the morty's home and stay
publican contra-sergeant confederates of
dedication of video game reality which
features an m for morty and marta the
game controllers symbolize their
dedication to staying within the
simulation one of the morty npcs can be
seen stealing toilet paper in the
apocalypse an all too familiar response
to impending global catastrophe after
decades of war choi's grocery has been
destroyed and marta's daughter informs
her mom that she's joining the other
side likewise larry begs marta to please
let him get on the spaceship that will
take him the other parts of morty back
to the real world and although marta
allows him to die inside the game she
realizes that she too is holding aspects
of morty hostage to her beliefs like her
father once did to her she finally
changes her mind and gives roy rick the
go-ahead to take the other npc morty's
home although rick swears that he got
all of morty out of the game it's
revealed after they leave by two arcade
employees that the roy game froze unable
to reset because roy died inside the
game shifting the storyline's focus to
an elderly marta living her best life
this means that that part of morty is
still trapped inside the game which
becomes apparent when he seems to trust
rick implicitly as they head off on
their next adventure it makes sense that
he's behaving like this like i said
earlier marta was clearly the part of
morty with independent thought and who
questioned rick's motives and decisions
and now that she's chosen to live inside
the game forever that part of morty is
absent irl although the employees make
it sound like arik purchased the machine
so that he could later extract this part
of morty i don't know they referred to
him as a rich old guy and i didn't know
that this dude was rich i mean
technically rick c137 has definitely
stolen bartered for or purchased a ton
of rare items over the years but i
refuse to trust an off-screen rick
because we didn't see him expressly ask
for the game let alone pick it up my
rogue's theory is that rick prime was
the buyer think about it he could
totally suck marta's morty out of the
game and upload it into his own morty to
rival our morty or worse he could hold
that part of morty hostage rendering him
useless to his chosen grandpa if this
looks familiar the roy machine is being
held in a storage center that's
reminiscent of hanger 51 from indiana
jones that's it for the breakdown but i
do have a little heads up for you guys
i'm going on vacation next week so my
very good best buddy mt is gonna take
the wheel for episode three i trust mt
with both my portal gun and my life and
i know he's gonna knock this next
breakdown out of the central finite
curve so please please please show him
some love i'll see you guys back here
for episode four so stay tuned follow me
on instagram and twitter whitneypuppy
follow new rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
do
[Music]
you